hello i'm caslin fields and i'm a
developer advocate at google cloud
focused on gke google kubernetes engine
as well as open source kubernetes
in this episode of gk essentials we'll
take a look at a key element of your gk
security posture authorization or access
management specifically with regard to
workloads
for a broader look at gk security be
sure to check out our introduction to
securing cluster access video
[Music]
when it comes to gke there are two
distinct types or levels of
authorization that you should be
familiar with
google cloud i am and kubernetes
role-based access control or rbac
the iam in google cloud i am stands for
identity and access management basically
im tools are what you use to set up
rules for who can do what to which
resources
the who in identity and access
management is going to be some form of
account
and i am allows you to set limits on
what that account can do and with which
resources in google
cloud you can design your own custom im
roles but for gke there are also several
predefined cloud im roles to quickly and
relatively easily provide granular
access to kubernetes engine resources
the gke viewer role gives read-only
access as might be needed for auditing
the gke developer role is suited to
developers and release engineers it
grants full control to all resources
within a cluster
the gk admin role gives full access to
clusters and the kubernetes engine
resources inside the clusters
example users are project owners system
administrators and on-call engineers
the gk cluster admin role is used to
create delete update and view clusters
but provides no access to kubernetes
resources within the cluster
you can also create a custom role in
google cloud i am to create a role with
a more minimal set of permissions than
those that are predefined
so google cloud im can be used to
control google cloud users access to the
gk cluster and its related resources for
managing access to resources within the
cluster kubernetes has its own similar
concept role-based access controls or
rbac
separate accounts are needed within the
cluster to control cluster users access
just like with cloud i am rbac is the
tool for configuring who can do what
with which resources within the cluster
so cloud im lets you manage who can do
what to which resources at the cloud
level controlling access to the google
cloud project gk cluster and other
resources like cloud storage
kubernetes role-based access control or
rbac manages who can do what with which
resources within the cluster
on kubernetes resources like deployments
persistent volumes etc
but what if the thing you want to give
permissions to isn't a user but a
workload running within kubernetes
for cases where the who is a workload
both google cloud i am and kubernetes
are back have a concept called a service
account
at this point it can get a bit confusing
there's something called a service
account at both the cloud and kubernetes
level
a kubernetes service account is part of
your kubernetes cluster and it can be
used to give a workload running within
the cluster access to other parts of the
cluster its scope is contained within
the kubernetes cluster
a google cloud service account is part
of your google cloud project
the who of a google cloud service
account can be a google cloud resource
like a gke cluster which can be given
permissions via im to access other cloud
resources
so what if you have a situation where a
workload running within gke needs access
to some other google cloud resource like
bigquery
[Music]
to get permissions all the way from a
workload within kubernetes to other
resources running in google cloud
in the most granular way possible
another concept is needed to tie the two
service account concepts together
that concept is workload identity
workload identity can be used to
automatically connect a google cloud
service account to a kubernetes service
account so that any workloads
represented by the kubernetes service
account will have the access described
by the gcp service account in order to
use any google cloud apis products or
services that workload might need
workload identity provides granular
control offering just the right
permissions to a particular workload
rather than to for example a whole
compute node or a whole cluster which
may have multiple workloads running on
them that don't need the same level of
access
you would configure workload identity
using something similar to the two
commands shown here
the first command at the top uses the
gcloud tool to make a call to the gcp
apis to create a policy binding granting
the kubernetes service account access to
act as the associated google cloud
service account
the second command at the bottom uses
the cubectl tool to use kubernetes apis
to annotate the kubernetes service
account with the name of the google
cloud service account it will act as
these concepts can be a little confusing
at first but workload identity can help
make access management for workloads
running within your gk clusters much
smoother and easier to manage
in this episode we talked about managing
access to resources at the cloud and
cluster levels and about simplifying
access management for kubernetes
workloads via google cloud workload
identity
with the concepts discussed in this
video we're confident you'll be on your
way to building a gk cluster that suits
your needs
you can get started with gke by visiting
the google cloud console and checking
out the links below and stay tuned for
our next videos where we dive deeper
into gk topics
[Music]